CHICAGO AT THE INTERSECTION
WHERE SMOLLETT SAID THAT HE WAS
ATTACKED, MATT.
>> Matt: TUCKER BEHIND ME, THE
POLICE SAY THAT BEAST MXP EIGHT
USE TO GET INTO HIS APARTMENT
BUILDING THAN I THE NIGHT OF THE
ATTACK AND WE ARE LEARNING
JUSSIE SMOLLETT CONVICTED OF DUI
AND LYING TO THE POLICE IN 2007
ACCORDING TO COURT DOCUMENTS
OBTAINED BY FOX NEWS.
THIS ARREST WAS CONFIRMED BY
L.A. CLERK THAT SAID THE
36-YEAR-OLD, THE BIRTHDAY
MATCHES THE BIRTHDAY OF JUSSIE
SMOLLETT ARRESTED FOR THE DUI
AND GIVING FALSE INFORMATION TO
THE POLICE.
WE REACHED OUT TO SMOLLETT IN A
LEGAL TEAM WHO DID NOT DENY HIS
ARREST.
WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
PINPOINT WHAT HE LIED TO THE
POLICE ABOUT, BUT A CHARGE.
SMOLLETT SENTENCED TO 36 MONTHS
PROBATION.
ALSO NEW TONIGHT, CHICAGO POLICE
TELLS FOX NEWS, CBS REPORTS
COMFORT -- CARRYING OUT AND MET
WITH PROSECUTORS AND DETECTIVES
LATE THIS AFTERNOON.
TONIGHT, CHICAGO POLICE STILL
WAITING FOR SMOLLETT TO RESPOND
TO REQUEST FOR A FOLLOW-UP
INTERVIEW.
THE PLACE A GIVEN SMOLLETT A
RESPONSIBLE AMOUNT OF TIME.
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT DEPENDS ON
SMOLLETT'S ACTIONS.
THE CASE TO PROSECUTORS OR A
GRAND JURY AND ARREST, WARRANT
AND TONIGHT THE POLICE APPEAR TO
BE DOING JUST THAT.
SMOLLETT WAS VERY COOPERATIVE
WITH THE POLICE BEFORE THIS
WHOLE STORY DRAMATICALLY NO
LONGER APPARENTLY RESPONDING TO
PHONE CALLS TO THE POLICE
REQUESTING MORE INFORMATION.
TONIGHT, THE POLICE NO LONGER
SAYING THAT SMOLLETT IS THE
VICTIM BUT THE PERSON WHO FILED
THE POLICE REPORT.
SMOLLETT'S ATTORNEY SAID ANYONE
WHO SAID SMOLLETT WAS NOT
ATTACKED AS A LIAR AND HERE, APE
FALSE POLICE REPORT IS A FELONY,
PUNISHABLE UP TO THREE YEARS IN
PRISON AND ALSO PROBATIONAL.
SMOLLETT MIGHT BE IN MORE
TROUBLE WITH THE FBI WHO IS
INVESTIGATING THAT ALLEGED DEATH